I used to drive when I drove over I
picked up these four girls I asked him
like what're you guys doing out here
tonight oh we're out here on holiday
just chillin so I get up in madrone I
said like three of my skateboard friends
you know and they they're like hella
like you know not like super hip or
whatever but I'm I was [ __ ] this is all
we got I need some wingmen so so I'm
dancing with one girl and she goes hey
do you guys like the party here in
America and I'm like wait do you mean
like dude like do blow she goes yeah I
don't know how common it is I'm here in
America I'm like don't say no more I'll
be right back and I go to my boy who
happened to be over there I'm a yo man I
never bought cocaine prior to December
somebody yo you know let me get you know
I got $10 I got $10 so we're taking the
girls back and I gave him some I gave
him all day on a little bag and they all
went to the bathroom right and then they
just bust out I never start dancing oh
[ __ ] it man so I got I was [ __ ] up by
the way I forgot to keep that I was
stuck and [ __ ] up I've been drinking
all night I did some drugs and I was
[ __ ] up and so we get to the to the to
the hostel I'm like yo y'all go ahead do
your thing I'm gonna sit down for a
little bit it was all trash and [ __ ] and
then I literally closed my eyes then I
opened my eyes and the movie theater was
clean hey what the [ __ ] and I see my
homies inside of this cafe at my yo what
the [ __ ] what happened what happened
with the girls I wait what
like it's 3 o'clock what the [ __ ]
happened like that I read for you yeah
pretty p.m. you know I do you passed out
we try to wake you up but you kept on
like going like this until you passed
out so we just you know we took the
chicks and we all had like a big-ass
orgy and we're doing cocaine over their
titties and he showed me [ __ ] photos
at him like like what lies a blow I on
the girls titties and [ __ ] and like oh
my god
here go change beer cocaine
[Music]